-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
today, President Biden
received a briefing on
the upcoming hurricane season
and talked about what the U.S.
is doing to prepare for it.
Yep. Biden was like,
"Are you reading the news?
My whole presidency
has been hurricane season."
But Biden's confident
the U.S. will be prepared.
He said, "I'll know when
the big hurricane is coming
when my right knee
starts aching."
Ooh! Yeah, you feel it.
Something's coming.
Meanwhile, last night,
Pennsylvania held its
Senate primary elections.
And while Dr. Oz is in the lead
for the Republican nomination,
more votes have to be counted
because the race
is still too close to call.
But this is kind of great.
I mean, for once, it's nice
to have a doctor waiting for us.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
"We're not ready yet. Almost."
Yeah, as of right now,
Dr. Oz is in first place,
David McCormick is in second,
and the "Cash Me Outside" girl
is in third.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Former president Trump
endorsed Dr. Oz
and he thinks Dr. Oz
should just declare victory now.
Dr. Oz was like,
"Donald, I think you're
suffering from
premature election."
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Election.
-If Dr. Oz does win,
he'll go on to face the winner
of last night's Democratic
primary, John Fetterman.
Can we see what that matchup
would look like?
Yeah. It's a
morning-talk-show host
against a morning-talk-show
host's security guard.
Let's get to some fun news.
I want to say congrats to
the class of 2022,
because it's
officially graduation season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Congratulations. You did it.
Yeah.
Saw the kids out on the street
today looking good.
Congrats.
And get this.
Today, Taylor Swift delivered
the NYU commencement address
at Yankee Stadium.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Of course,
the ceremony lasted a while,
because Taylor did the speech
once, then had to re-record it.
But it's commencement season,
which is when famous speakers
give helpful advice
to graduates.
So, with that in mind,
here with some sound advice
is our sound engineer,
Steve Mandel.
Steve?
-Always give like
30% effort at work.
That way, when you give 50%,
they'll be like, "Wow.
He's really working hard."
-[ Whispering ]
Sound advice from Steve Mandel.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
That's nice.
It's good to see Steve.
-Great advice.
-You guys see this?
Australian Prime Minister
Scott Morrison
is out on the campaign trail,
alright?
And today, he played soccer
with some young kids.
Yeah, let's see how that went.
Yep. Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
That's amazing.
It took himself, the kid,
and his campaign down under.
It's interesting.
Well, guys, we have Tim McGraw
here on the show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The one and only.
Yep, he stars in the
"Yellowstone"
spin-off series "1883."
And now I saw that
Helen Mirren and Harrison Ford
are starring in another
"Yellowstone" spin-off
called "1932."
Yep, "1932" will focus on
the pandemic, historic drought,
and the depression,
or, as everyone in 2022 put it,
"Gee, what's that like?"
Some more entertainment news.
The game show
"Wheel of Fortune" is going on
its first-ever live tour.
And we actually got a
sneak peek of the first episode.
Take a look at this.
-Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
[ Cymbal crash ]
-What?
-It looks intense.
-Yeah. Wow!
-How about some more advice
from Steve Mandel?
Steve, anything?
-Find a need, fill a need.
For example,
I sell urine to guys on parole.
-[ Whispering ]
Sound advice from Steve Mandel.
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Find a need and fill a need.
-Wow!
-Hey, guys,
this has been going viral.
The world's most
inconvenient convenience store
hangs off a cliff in China
and sells snacks to climbers.
Look at this. Check this out.
Look at this. Crazy.
-Oh!
-Yeah. And this is annoying.
It's cash only,
but there's an ATM 5 miles up.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
And, finally, is time for our
latest installment of
"Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show Polls" ♪
-This first poll asks...
-Oh.
-This next poll asks...
"The 'n."
This next one asked...
What?
This next one asks...
Interesting.
This next one is interesting.
This next poll asks,
"Do you prefer sitting
in a booth or at a table?"
What do you think, Higgins?
-I'm going to say booth.
-Yeah. What do you think, Tariq?
You feel like a
booth type of guy.
-I'm definitely a booth person.
-Quest?
-Booth.
-I think everyone goes
booth, right?
-I think.
Let's see what the poll says.
-Alright. 55% said...
-[ Laughs ]
Oh!
Indeed!
French fries? Feed them to me.
-I love sharing
my food with you.
-Mmm! Open the door!
-[ Laughs ]
Open the hangar!
We're adults. There we go.
This next poll asks...
This next poll asked...
♪ Softly, slowly ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
[ Laughter ]
The last poll asked...
That's all the time we have for
"Tonight Show Polls."
What a great show tonight.